[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport angelo von mir und das sind einige
unsere themen heute
plädoyer für einheitliche corona
maßnahmen die ministerpräsidenten der
länder wollen für den winter einen regel
flickenteppich vermeiden
migrations strategie gesucht beim
letzten eu-gipfel von kanzlerin merkel
ringt europa um einen gemeinsamen kurs
gegenüber belarus und
ein neuer kunst schreien für den schrei
in oslo eröffnet das museum seine
pforten
die korona neuinfektionen werden in den
kommenden wochen noch sehr viel
schneller steigen davor warnt das robert
koch-institut trotzdem plädiert
gesundheitsminister sparen dafür die
epidemische notlage ende november
auslaufen zu lassen eine einheitliche
rechtsgrundlage müsse es aber geben
fordern heute die bundesländer auf ihrer
jahrestagung
denn schon jetzt gehen die zahlen rasant
nach oben 19
1572 neue corona fälle wurden binnen 24
stunden registriert gut 8000 mehr als
vor einer woche deutlich der trend auch
bei der inzidenz seit ende september
statt zeigt die kurve wieder steil
aufwärts aktueller stand 95,1 klarer
spitzenreiter ist der kreis
berchtesgadener land mit einem wert von
400 28,9 alles zur corona lage von
thomas münten
mühldorf am inn bayern aktuelle ins
events über 450 man sieht da von nichts
es gibt kein lockdown keine
geschlossenen schulen keine verriegelten
restaurants im landratsamt bleiben sie
relativ ruhig weil die lage trotzdem
eine andere ist als vor einem jahr wir
haben eine situation dass hauptsächlich
die ungeimpften momentan die betroffen
sind sind der weit überwiegende teil
derer die sich jetzt infizieren ist
ungeübte der weit überwiegende teil der
personen die ins krankenhaus müssen ist
ungewiss und der weit überwiegende teil
derer die auf der intensivstation landen
ist umgehend also auch mehr impfungen
hoffen und die bundesweiten pandemie
regeln zum 25 november aufheben wie es
gesundheitsminister sparen vorgeschlagen
hat nein sagen heute die
ministerpräsidentinnen aus 16 ländern
der bund muss sicherstellen dass basis
schutzmaßnahmen für herbst und winter
dass es dafür eine rechtsgrundlage gibt
wenn jedes land das selbst festlegen
muss führt das zu verwerfungen auch
virologen unterstützen die ansicht der
regierungschefs wir sehen ja heute wie
die zahlen sich bewegen welche richtung
sie gehen das war zu erwarten und es ist
zu erwarten dass es noch weiter nach
oben geht mit den fallzahlen impfungen
und lockt bei uns hätten einen in europa
viel beachteten erfolg gebracht da sind
sich die ministerpräsidentinnen sicher
weil wir diesen erfolg teilweise ja auch
schmerzhaft erkauft haben mit unseren
maßnahmen waren wir uns heute doch sehr
einig dass wir kein risiko eingehen
sollten zumindest die möglichkeit neuer
einheitlicher pandemie maßnahmen wollen
die bundesländer auch nach dem 25
november erhalten
fragen wir schon container pannergy in
berlin bislang hat jedes bundesland die
korona regeln nach eigenem ermessen
ausgelegt warum jetzt dieses pochen auf
einheitlichkeit der offensichtlich weil
sich die bundesländer nicht zu trauen
ist in eigenregie wirklich einheitlich
hinzubekommen das hat er in der
vergangenheit während der gesamten
pandemie auch nicht wirklich gut
geklappt hat es eben jeder hat jeder
seine spielräume so genutzt und jetzt
steuern sie auf eine unbequeme situation
zu wenn in vier wochen die epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite auslaufen
sollte muss man eine neue regelung
finden sonst landet die verantwortung
bei den ländern es gibt da aktuell drei
möglichkeiten entweder der bundestag
verlängert die epidemische lage das ist
aber nicht besonders populär oder
erinnert das infektionsschutzgesetz so
dass schutzmaßnahmen auch ohne
epidemische lage möglich sind auch das
wird sicherlich kritik hervorrufen oder
dritte möglichkeit man lässt das
tatsächlich einfach auslaufen dann
können immer noch die länder selber in
eigenregie entscheiden welche
schutzmaßnahmen sie welche
schutzmaßnahmen sie ergreifen in
abstimmung mit den länderparlamenten
aber das wird natürlich kompliziert und
schutzmaßnahmen sind nicht immer populär
man muss sie immer kritisch hinterfragen
man muss sie immer diskutieren und
begründen das in 16 bundesländern
einzelnen durchzuziehen das wird dann
tatsächlich ganz schön kompliziert
dankeschön schack und alain bernard aus
berlin
dramatisch wird entwickelt sich die
korona lage in russland die behörden
melden so viele neue infektionen wie
noch nie binnen 24 stunden gab es mehr
als 37.000 neue corona fälle mehr als
1000 menschen starben
und das sind nur die offiziellen zahlen
großes problem die impfskepsis der
bevölkerung christiansen hat details
fast 80 tote in den letzten zwei tagen
alleine hier indischen dorf geholt jeden
tag ein neuer trauriger rekord bei den
todeszahlen und neuinfektionen in
russland und das wahre ausmaß ist wohl
noch größer experten zweifeln die
offiziellen zahlen an die zahlen unserer
statistik sind stark untertrieben die
aktuellen zahlen sind drei bis
dreieinhalb mal höher das heißt dass
jetzt rund 3000 menschen pro tag sterben
nicht weniger
lange hat man in russland einfach laufen
lassen corona hatten viele schon
vergessen geringe einschränkungen des
staates lasche massenkontrollen dazu
eine weitverbreitete im skepsis erst 30
prozent der bevölkerung sind komplett
gewinnt in einigen regionen fehlt es an
sauerstoff intensivstation am limit
die gesamte intensivstation ist voll von
patienten in sehr kritischem zustand all
diese patienten sind ungeimpft
nun ein kleiner lockdown der nicht so
heißen soll ab ende nächster woche hat
präsident putin corona frei verordnet im
hotspot moskau schließen restaurants
geschäfte schulen und kindergärten
kontakt beschränkungen im privaten aber
gibt es nicht sie dienen ja damit eine
woche zu hause sitzen treffen mit
freunden nicht zur arbeit gehen ohne
chor ohne regeln einzuhalten hat kein
ob die maßnahmen ausreichen die pandemie
einzudämmen mehr als fraglich viele
wollen die freien tage nutzen und urlaub
machen sotschi am schwarzen meer
erwartet einen besucheransturm
china bedroht seit monaten zunehmend
aggressiv sein nachbarland taiwan peking
betrachtet das land als abtrünnige
provinz jetzt hat sich us-präsident
beiden eingeschaltet und zugesichert
taiwan militärisch zu verteidigen sollte
es von china angegriffen werden solchen
beistand garantierten die usa in asien
bislang nur engen verbündeten wie japan
und südkorea das außenministerium in
peking warnte washington sich nicht in
chinesische angelegenheiten einzumischen
herr matti wissen in washington wie
gefährlich kann das werden
ja der us präsident will mit seinen
worten zumindest abschrecken weil er
befürchtet dass es brandgefährlich wird
wenn china tatsächlich versuchen sollte
eine invasion zu starten gegenteil war
oder wenn die vielen militärischen
provokationen in der region aus dem
ruder laufen china hat in den
vergangenen wochen mehr als 150 mal
flugzeuge kampfbomber und chats in die
region geschickt über taiwan den
luftraum verletzt china entwickelt auch
neue raketen darunter eine die angeblich
in der lage sein soll mit fünffacher
schallgeschwindigkeit
nukleare sprengsätze auch in chile in
die usa zu bringen das macht mir große
sorgen und jetzt ist die frage am ende
über das was man schon getan hat hinaus
nämlich bündnisse zu schließen mit
australien gerade kürzlich auch die
bereitschaft selber neue moderne
mittelstreckenraketen in der region zu
stationieren ob man wirklich in den
krieg ziehen würde wenn china taiwan
angreift berater des präsidenten hinter
den kulissen zweifeln eigentlich daran
aber man will glaube ich ein bisschen
die selbstgewissheit chinas erschüttern
das davon ausgeht dass man taiwan
möglicherweise wieder vereinigen kann
mit china ohne dass die usa tatsächlich
eingreifen da wollen die usa damit das
weiße haus zweifel säen
sie wissen war das live aus washington
vielen dank
nach brüssel wo heute ein besonderer eu
gipfel zu ende ging der 100 siebte für
bundeskanzlerin merkel und eben
vermutlich der letzte da wurde manche
europäische spitze und fast sentimentale
ein europäischer rat ohne merkel sei wie
rom ohne den vatikan oder paris ohne den
eiffelturm so ratspräsidentschaft
michelle inhaltlich dagegen ging es mal
wieder weniger harmonisch zu gunnar
krüger berichtet auch auf dem letzten
gipfel mit angela merkel hat jede und
jeder einen standpunkt darum kommt die
eu nicht vom fleck nicht letzten acht
dem justiz streit mit polen nicht heute
beim anderen dauer thema der migration
die baustellen für meinen nachfolger
sind groß das geht einmal an diese
fragen der rechtsstaatlichkeit war das
ist eben auch das thema migration was
wir halt noch nicht unter uns gelöst
haben velaro rus nutzt das aus führt in
polen migration herbei will die eu damit
spalten und schafft das auch schon bei
der frage wer für neuen technischen
grenzschutz bezahlen soll das heißt
drohnen sollen oder etwas anderes dass
diese auch von der eu mitfinanziert
werden die rechtsgrundlagen dazu gibt es
muss nur noch den politischen willen
geben sie sind uns in kommission und
parlament seit langem einig wir
finanzieren keine mauern und zäune
der zaun streit ist klein verglichen mit
dem um eine neue eu migrationspolitik
frankreich übernimmt ja die initiative
doch makro ist alles nur nicht merklich
frau merkel war so ne kompromiss
maschine den kritiker in kritischen
momenten war angela die lady di
einschritt und die lösung fand nur eben
nicht bei der migration trotzdem gab es
zum abschied heute stehenden applaus und
als souvenir eins dieser kunstwerke
ihr lasst uns keine wahl unter diesem
motto haben 10.000 umweltschützer in
berlin deutlich gemacht was er sich von
der künftigen bundesregierung erwarten
der klimaschutz müsse endlich ins
zentrum der politischen agenda rücken
uns irgendwie
protest vor der spd zentrale
sie wollen druck auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen ausüben das 1,5
grad ziel auch wirklich einzuhalten
dafür waren die freude ist für feature
demonstranten heute in massen nach
berlin gekommen
jetzt wird gerade an unserer zukunft
geschrieben an der zukunft dieses landes
und jetzt haben wir die chance
einzugreifen ich denke eigentlich müsste
jeder mal kapieren warum wir hier sind
aber es gibt so viele leute die das
alles noch so wenig ernst nehmen vor
allem fordern sie eine schnellere
umsetzung der klimaziele den
kohleausstieg etwa schon bis 2030 bis
dahin auch 80 prozent erneuerbare
energien in der stromerzeugung in
neufahrzeugen sollten schon ab 2025
keine verbrennungsmotoren mehr verbaut
werden forderungen die bisher nur
teilweise in den opel-verhandlungen eine
rolle gespielt haben wir waren drei
jahre auf der straße und sind
unglaublich wütend dass noch immer keine
partei tatsächlich konkrete maßnahmen
vorlegt wie wir die 15 grad grenze
einhalten und wir werden hier sein wir
werden weiter druck machen und laut
seinen bisschen vernünftiges
koalitionspapier rauskommt schon für das
wochenende sind unter dem motto
solidarisch geht anders neue proteste in
berlin angekündigt dann für einen sozial
gerechten ökologischen wandel
ein drama erschüttert hollywood und
wirft fragen auf über den umgang mit
waffen am filmset der schauspieler alec
baldwin hat mit einer requisiten waffe
offenbar versehentlich zwei menschen
getroffen eine 42-jährige kamerafrau ist
tot der regisseur schwer verletzt
passiert ist das bei den dreharbeiten zu
einem western in santa fe baldwin ist
hauptdarsteller und produzent claudia
bertz berichtet der drehort für den
western auf einer ranch kurz nachdem es
passiert war polizei am filmset nachdem
echte schüsse gefallen waren aus einer
requisiten waffe der schütze
hauptdarsteller alec baldwin hier mit
seinem ganzen team
die kamerafrau halina hutchins wurde
tödlich getroffen
42 jahre alt sie galt als neuer stern am
himmel hollywood als ganz besonderes
talent der regisseur joe sutter wurde
verletzt konnte das krankenhaus wohl
inzwischen verlassen in einem tweet hat
sich baldwin geäußert es gibt keine
worte um einen schock und meine trauer
auszudrücken über den tragischen unfall
der halina hudgens das leben genommen
hat eine ehefrau mutter und zutiefst
bewunderte kollegin ich bin in kontakt
mit ihrem mann und biete ihm und ihrer
familie unterstützung an mein herz ist
gebrochen für ihren mann ihren sohn und
alle die alina kannten und liebten
die polizei ermittelt noch gegen baldwin
richten sich momentan keine vorwürfe auf
fotos nach seinem verhör sieht man den
hollywood-star und vater von sechs
kleinen kindern als gebrochenen mann wie
konnte das passieren
experte larry sennhof spricht von
eigentlich strengen kontrollen an
filmsets
ich frage mich wurden die
sicherheitsrichtlinien unserer industrie
befolgt platzpatronen haben ja nicht
solche folgen wir müssen herausfinden
was hier schief gegangen ist
ein erster hinweis kommt von der
hollywood gewerkschaft versehentlich sei
scharfe munition in der waffe gewesen
die produktion des films wurde
ausgesetzt
so sieht es aus wenn norwegen seinem
berühmtesten maler ein denkmal setzt
etwa trug sein neues viel größeres
museum thront am oslofjord und mit ihm
der wohl umstrittenste knick norwegens
die einen sagen das museum wolle sich
verbeugen vor der stadt ihren bewohnern
von der kunst andere erinnert das
gebäude an eine leitplanke
so hat calli nimmt uns mit hinein
mehr weit sein schreien sein
berühmtestes werk kein einzelstück
edward munkert es mehrfach gemeint
und auch seine großformatigen werke wie
die sonne bekommen zum ersten mal den
raum den sie verdienen insgesamt
27.000 gemälde drucke und zeichnungen
ein wichtiger teil unserer identität
unserer kultur und unserer
kunstgeschichte historie
13 geschosse für die kunst platz für elf
ausstellungen eine aussichtsplattform
eine bibliothek restaurants 1 rund 280
millionen euro hat das fulminante
kunsthaus gekostet
willi fantastisches gebäude ein museum
das inspiriert
cooles gebäude in dem die kunst von
edward muss sehr stylisch präsentiert
wird
nein ich finde das gebäude nicht schön
ist zu groß und zu grau
mehr money es ist das größte museum der
welt aus einem einzelnen künstler
gewidmet ist
dieses museum ist ein statement ein
imperativ das für die bedeutung von munk
und seinem werk steht
das neue webos los neue ikone allein für
das kommende wochenende rechnen sie mit
25.000 besucher
udo zimmermann war der star komponist
der ddr einer der führenden
zeitgenössischen komponisten überhaupt
nun ist er im alter von 78 jahren
gestorben
mehr als zehn jahre leitete er die oper
leipzig dann die deutsche oper berlin ii
seine eigenen werke wie die weiße rose
über die geschwister scholl feierten
auch international erfolge
[Musik]
als dirigent gastierte er bei
renommierten orchestern wie den wiener
und berliner philharmoniker
und jetzt zum fußball norbert mit leider
hässlichen bildern und rotterdam
allerdings bei der konferenz
league-partie fei nord gegen union
berlin gab es einen umstrittenen
polizeieinsatz gegen gästefans bei dem
einige union anhänger verletzt wurden ja
und auch sportlich lief es für die
berliner alles andere als erfreulich
drin im stadion fallen die tore 3 zu 1
sieg gastgeber ferienort rotterdam doch
die magische fußball nacht bekommt
außerhalb des stadions ein hässliches
gesicht vor dem gästeblock kommt es zu
verspäteten einlass eine gruppe von 59
union-fans soll die konfrontation suchen
union anhänger sprechen hingegen von
willkürlichen festnahmen 75 insgesamt
und erheblicher polizeigewalt ein
polizeihund soll drei union fans
krankenhausreif gebissen haben zur
gewalt hat einfach im fußball nichts
verloren und da bin ich ein bisschen
traurig darüber auf dem feld war alles
respektvoll und so soll es auch sein das
rückspiel in zwei wochen findet
mutmaßlich unter hohen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen statt
friedlich dagegen ging es beim 3 2 1
-erfolg der frankfurter gegen den
griechischen rekordmeister olympiakos
piräus zu übrigens der erste heimsieg
der eintracht in einem pflichtspiel in
dieser saison
endlich mal wieder so eine magische
europapokal nachdem frankfurt lange
hatten die fans darauf gewartet
hochkarätige torchancen gleich zu beginn
noch ohne torerfolg und ganz zum ärger
von trainer glasner eins zu eins durch
zwei elfmeter tore nach 30 minuten doch
mehr und mehr spielt sich die eintracht
danach in einen rausch zurück in die
herzen ihrer fans vergessen der graue
alltag in der liga stattdessen
mitreißender offensivfußball diese
traumkombination abgeschlossen durch
turi ein weiterer treffer durch kanada
zum 3 1 endstand in der zweiten halbzeit
und da war sie wieder diese magische
europapokal nacht in frankfurt
frankfurt dem glück dortmund im
verletzungspech der top-torjäger der
borussen erling holland wird erneut
mehrere wochen ausfallen diesmal wegen
hüftproblemen wieder
gold für deutschland bei der bahnrad-wm
in ruby und zwar für den frauen vierer
franziska brause lisa brennauer mieke
kröger und laura süßemilch bezwang im
finale das quartett aus italien das
deutsche team hatte auch bei olympia und
bei der em gold gewonnen und
komplettiert nun das titel triple
glückwunsch das wasser fort danke schön
und wir haben noch einen ziemlich
spektakulären blick auf manhattan in 330
metern höhe befindet sich new yorks
neueste attraktion hoch oben im
wolkenkratzern vanderbilt liegt einem
die stadt zu füßen im gegensatz zu all
den anderen
aussichtsplattformen bietet diese hier
den transparenten blick nach unten muss
man mögen
die stürmischen zeiten gehen hierzulande
zu ende das wochenende bringt sonniges
herbstwetter zum teil auch mal neben das
heute journal um 10 mit marietta slomka
danke für ihr interesse ein schönes
wochenende ihnen und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das hier ist das letzte was
wir unserem sturmtief noch übrig
geblieben ist es ist ein regenband das
heute von der nordsee weiter in richtung
süden zog und dahinter lockerten die
wolken schon wieder auf da gab es zum
teil kräftige schauer dieses wolkenband
beschäftigt uns auch noch in der nacht
da fällt ein bisschen regen im norden
sind einige schauer unterwegs sonst ist
es aber häufig auch klar oder nur locker
bewölkten da wird es kalt in den
mittelgebirgen und südlich der donau
sinken die werte auf plus 3 bis minus 1
grad da droht also überall bodenfrost
sonst bleibt die nacht bei 9 bis 4 grad
milder und die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen ganz ähnliche heute zwischen 7
grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen und
13 grad auf den ostfriesischen inseln am
nieder oder am oberrhein und morgen wird
ein freundlicher sonnabend sonne und
wolken wechseln sich ab und am
strahlenden scheint die sonne zwischen
dem alpenrand und dem schwarzwald am
sonntag sieht es ganz ähnlich aus nach
nebel und dunst zeigt sich häufig die
sonne und es wird mit 9 bis 14 grad
schon ein bisschen milder und das ist
dann auch die tendenz für die kommende
woche und erwarten am montag
höchsttemperaturen bis 18 grad am
dienstag wird es am besten etwas
unerfreulicher aber dann setzt sich doch
bald wieder freundliches wetter durch
guten abend